[Alkış]
şifası olmayan dert yoktur Her hastalık
iyileşebilir ama tabii ki her hasta
iyileşmez Biz canlıyız alınacak
nefesimiz var Her birimiz nefesimizi
alacağız yaşayacağız Önemli olan
dünyadayken yaşadığınız her günü her
anın sağlıkla yaşayabilmek Peki nedir
sağlık bizim vücudumuzda bizim sağlıklı
olmamızı
gerçekleştiren nedir hastalıklar nasıl
iyileşir bugün biraz onlardan
bahsedeceğiz rakamlar görüyorsunuz 2018
yılında Türkiye'de yaklaşık 800 milyon
hasta başvurusu var 85 milyonluk
memlekette bu kadar çok hasta olması
normal değil aynı zamanda iki buçuk
milyarın üzerinde kutu tüketilmiş ilaç
tüketilmiş iki buçuk milyar kutu yıllık
ilaç hepimiz hastayız hastalara Rus ve
piton ilaçlarla yaşıyoruz oysa o normal
değil tarihin hiçbir öneminde de böyle
işi görmedik
beslenme canlılığın aktarılmasıdır Biz
vücudumuzda üretemediğimiz maddelerin
dışarıdan almak için besleniriz ve her
birimiz gıdaya muhtacız olay sadece
protein yağ ve karbonhidrat meselesi
değildir Olay aslında insanın vücudunda
üretemediği Omega ölçüleri vitaminleri
mineralleri flaminatleri dışarıdan
alması meselesidir sadece kalori hesabı
ile beslenmeyi anlatamazsınız
ikinci beğeniyoruz bağırsaklara Çünkü
bağırsaklarımızda beynimizdeki kadar
sinir hücresi var Her biriniz Öncü
olduğunda yaklaşık olarak 350
metrekarelik büyüklüğünde bağırsaklar
var bu bağırsaklar şu anda bulunduğumuz
salondan daha büyük yer kaplıyor Ve her
birimiz vücudundaki bağırsaklar aynı
zamanda son derece kalabalık bağışıklık
sistemi hücrelerimize bağırsaklarda
görev yapıyor probiyotiklerimiz var 100
trilyonun üzerinde ve Tabi ki enteriks
sinir sistemi var bizim bağırsaklarımız
niye bu kadar büyük niye bu kadar
kalabalık ve niye bu kadar çok sinir
hücresi içeriyor bağışıklık sistemi niye
orada Çünkü bizim bağırsaklarımız
aslında bir gıda Manisa laboratuvarı
gibi çalışır bağırsaklarımız Bizim Gıda
için yediğimiz her gün yiyecek içecek
olarak ülkemize aldığımız yaklaşık
olarak 3-4 kilo yabancı maddeyi Kahvaltı
yapıyoruz ve ben yemeği yiyoruz Akşam
yemeği soğuk çay kahve bu 3-4 kilo
yabancı maddeyi bünyemizi alıyoruz gıda
olarak Oysa gıdalarla Birlikte pek çok
yabancı madde de alıyoruz bizim için
zararlı maddede alıyoruz bizim bağırsak
duvarımız tıpkı bir gıdığınız
laboratuvarı gibi çalışır ve aldığımız
Gıdalara analiz edip içindeki Fito
kimyasalların hepsini tek tek ayırt edip
zararları uzaklaştırıp faydalıları
parçalayarak sindirime geçer Yani
aslında bağırsakla bizim için dünyanın
hiçbir yerinde var olmayan
gıda analiz laboratuvarlarıdır Peki ben
her gün zararlı gıda yersen ne olur
bağışıklık sistemini Bağışıklık
sisteminin %85'i niye bağırsaklarda
çalışıyor işte burada ayağını
desteklemek için bu gıda analiz
laboratuvarların işçileri
problemlerinizin vücudunda 100 trilyonun
üzerinde Probiyotik taşıyoruz İnsan
vücudunda yaklaşık olarak 10 trilyon
ücreti taşır gücüne sayınızın 10 katı
kadar probiyotikler bağırsaklarımızda ve
bunlar 4.500'ün üzerinde ayrı türden
oluşuyor Yani aslında probiyotikler
bizim için var olan yaşam için var olan
Probiyotik yaşam için olan demek Peki
probiyotiklerin probiyotikler bizim için
ne yapıyor kahve Aşk vitaminin üretiyor
vücudumuzdan vitamin üretilmez üretilen
tek vitamin kara ve aşk vitamindir yani
saçınızın sağlığından kanınızın
pıhtılaşmasına kadar proteinler önemli
burada
probiyotikler bizim bağışıklık
sistemimizi kontrol ediyor probiyotikler
Bizim her türlü hastalıktan korunmamızı
sağlıyor probiyotikler serotoninin %95
üretiyor hani şu hep anlatılıyor ya
Depresyonda serotonun eksikliği diye
işte depresyona girmenize engelleyen
serotoni %95 öğretiyor ve bu serotonin
vücudumuzda trombositlere bağlanarak
beynine kadar gidiyor kan beyin var
evinde geçiyor
probiyotiklerin Yokluğunda bakın neler
oluyor
kanserden diyabete enfeksiyonlardan
Oteli bir hastalıklara kadar pek çok
hastalık meydana geliyor biz
propolitikleri nereden alırız vücudumuza
gıdalardan alırız nedir Probiyotik
gıdalar fermente gıdalar sirke turşu
yoğurt kefir ama bunların hazır mayayla
üretilmiş olanı değil ev usulü üretilmiş
olanlarından Çünkü hazır Maya Probiyotik
maya değildir bizim vücudumuzda da
Probiyotik etki yapmaz benden sağlıklı
yaşamak istiyorsan ben Şifa bulmak
istiyorsam bir kere en önce beslenme
dikkat et
gıda canlıdır bozulmayan gıda benimle
sağlığım Bozar Dolayısıyla yediğimiz
gıda her şeyden önemlidir
insan genomunda 145 tane yabancı bakteri
gene bulundu Bu ne demek biliyor musunuz
Bizim probiyotiklerimiz bize yani
transferi yapıyor buna 35 sene önce
fakültede bize böyle öğretilmedi genetik
yapınız kaderinizdir değişmez nasıl
dolduysanız öyle ölürsünüz denildi Oysa
ki 8 sene önce bir tane 10 projesinde
çalışıldı ve görüntüdeki probiyotikler
bize gel transferi yapıyor yani
dediklerinizi içtiklerimiz Bildik bizim
genetik yapılması bile değiştiriyor
Bu ne demek ben yediklerimle
içtiklerimle hastalıklara karşı
korunabilirim veya hastalanabilirim
Üstelik genetik faktörleri bile
değiştireceğiz bu video genetik
faktörler benim kaderim değildir
herhangi bir yeni taşıyor olmam illa o
hastalığa yakalanacağım manasına gelmez
Eğer ben istersem genetik hastalıklardan
bile korunabilirim Nitekim bu gösterildi
Bugün artık genetik hastalıklara Nadir
hastalıkları veriyoruz yaşamın
biyolojisi her zaman iyiliğe erir
yaşamamız biyolojisinde Hiçbir zaman
kötü kazanmaz hastalık kazanmaz genetik
hastalık gelmeleri rekabet edilerek
Gider insan ve Yaşar sürekli iyileri
doğru tutar
burada genetiğine müdahale etmiş
gıdalardan bahsetmeye başarmamız gerek
eğer benim Yediğim içtiğim gıdalar benim
genetik yapımım bile değiştiriyorsa o
zaman GDO'lu gıdalar ve ıslah ettik
dedikleri tırnak içinde ıslah ettikleri
hibrit tohumlar benim vücuduma ne yapar
bu olay 1943'te başladı kritikamı eski
Hun Bir Buğday türü üzerinde Amerika
çalışmalar edeceğim dedi yine 10 versin
diye 20 versin denimini artıracağım dedi
Böylece de dünyada açtığın engelli
İcadiye ve bugün yediğimiz gibi
tohumları üretilmiş cüce buğdayı yarattı
tarihte yetişmiş olan insanların on bin
yıldır tarafını yaptığı buğdayın
tohumundan bambaşka bir tohum ürettiler
bu buğday tüketilmeye başladıktan sonra
bakın Ne oldu 1943 Bu da genetiğimiz
idare edildi 1953 dünyada ilk defa
Çölyak hastalığı tanımlandı çölyak
buğdayın içindeki gluten maddesine karşı
olan aşırı hassasiyete verdiğimiz isim
Aslında glutene Hiçbirimiz
sindiremiyoruz ama bazılarımız çok daha
şiddetli Reaksiyon veriyoruz eski
buğdayı tüketirken şöyle hastalık
dünyada görülmemişken biz yeni odayı
tüketmeye başladığınız ürünler itibaren
1953 ilk şöyle ya da görmeye başladık
çölyak klasik olarak gaz asılsızlık
şişkinlik ishal ya da kabızlık ağız
içinde yaralar eklem cilt eklem ağrıları
ve cilt döküntüleri beklenen bir
hastalık Oysa günümüze geldiğimizde
bambaşka bir çölyak çıktı
çölyak gibi değil sadece Fibromiyalji
ile başlayan çölyak tabldogyerci
diyabetle ortaya çıkan romatoid antik
olarak ortaya çıkan haşimat olarak
ortaya çıkan yani Aslında pek çok
hastalığın ana Sebep olarak çölyak çıktı
Türk dünyada 2000 yılından itibaren
tohum yasaları değiştirildi ve doğum
yasaları değiştirildikten sonra da biz
bütün dünyada ülkemizde de 2006'da
değiştirildi çölyakıt patlatarak gördük
burada size sunulan besin piramitini
görüyorsunuz Bu piramitte bir mısır
pirami gibi düşünün 86'dan itibaren
Amerikan diyabet çekecekti Ben kalpten
hastalıklarını engelleyeceğim kalpten
rahatsızlıklarının bir numaranın sebebi
diyabet diğer metali obeziteye
engellemek için bütün İnsanlara böyle
beslenmesini tavsiye ediyorum diye bu
piramiti çıkardı günümüzde aldıkları
tepkilerden dolayı artık piramit
demiyorlar ama aynı beslenme şekli
önermeye devam ediyorlar Mısır
piramidinin ucunda sivri kısmında yağlar
var kolesterol hikayesi sakın tüketmeyin
yağlar sizin damarlarınızı tıkıyor
dediler onun hemen altında et var onun
hemen altında sebzeden ve en altta
tam Tahıllar günlük kalorinin %60'ını
tam tahıllarla karşılayın dedi
niye dedi buna Amerikan devlet Cemiyeti
diyabeti engellemek ve obeziteye
engellemek için Peki ne oldu Amerika'da
bu programa geçirdikten sonra
artışı görüyorsunuz 2000 yılında
%6'larda olan diyabet oranı yüksele
yüksele bugün buralara geldi bu bütün
dünyadaki artışları 2000'li yıllarda 151
milyon olan diyabetli sayısı sayı olarak
425 bine ulaştı 2017'de sonra ne oldu
biliyor musunuz günümüze geldik
diyabet şu anda o kadar hızlı artıyor ki
Dünya Sağlık Örgütü diyabeti mikrobik
olmayan salgın hastalık olarak
adlandırılıyor günümüzde dünyadaki
erişkin nüfusun 537 milyonu Diyabet
hastası şu anda Bu salonda oturan
yetişkin insanların Türkiye'de yarısı
diyabet ve kıyamet ve bunların %90'a
teşhisi konulmuştur diyabet bizim insan
sağlığı açısından en tehlikeli
hastalığımız
Türkiye'deki ziyaret çalışmalarına
baktığımızda 98 ile %7,2 olan diyabetin
2010 yılında %13.7'ye çıktığını
görüyoruz korkunç bir tablo tarihte
böyle bir şey görülmemiş 12 sene
zarfında diyabet ikiye katlamış daha da
malim olanı bu 12 sene içinde prepya
beklediğimiz Durum tam 4,5 kat artmış
%6'lardan
%28.7'lere çıkmış inanılmaz bir artış
var burada ve bunun temelinde yatan asıl
sebep tohumların değişmesi beslenme
şekline değişmesidir Ben sizin
yaşınızdayken lisedeyken
üniversitedeyken eve gerek söylemek diye
bir kavram yoktu biz üniversite
hayatımız boyunca evde tencereye Yemek
pişirdik dışarı çıktığımızda da öğrenci
lokantalarda da hep yemek yerdik şimdi
bütün evler öğrenci evlerinden Vazgeçtim
hepsi eve yemek söylüyor ve insanlar
bunu bir kolaylık bir modernlik bir
Şehirli yaşamı olarak algılıyorlar
Oysaki Bu bize hasta eden temel
faktördür diyabetin artışının altında
yatan ana sebepte budur resmen ruhun
bozulması tohumların bozulması
Bu tablo bizim ne kadar Rahim olduğumuzu
daha iyi Açıklıyor Avrupa Birliği
ülkelerinde karşılaştırılabilir
preverans Litvanya 3.89 iniyoruz İtalya
5.3 İngiltere 4.9 indiriyoruz aşağılara
şu çizgi var ya gri olan dünya
ortalaması %8 Avrupa Birliği ortalaması
%5 en alttaki kırmızı çizgi Bizim
ülkemiz Türkiye'ye %15 Avrupa Birliği
ortalamasının 3 katı dünya ortalamasının
iki katı bir Evet görüyor ülkemizde
niye bu kadar önemli çünkü diyabet
sadece kan şekeri yüksekliği değildir
diyabet arka planda damar ve sinir
hasarı yaptığı için bütün sistemi tutan
bütün organları tutan bir hastalıktır ve
bakın diyabete bağlı ürünler ne kadar
6.7 milyon insan 2021 yılında diyabete
bağlı neden kaynaklanıyormuş dünyada en
fazla ölüme yol açan hastalık grubu kalp
ve damar Has stadıdır kalp ve damar
hastalıkların bir numaralı nitelik
diyabettir kolesterol yüksekliği
değildir ve biz diyabetle mücadele
edemiyoruz GDO İnsanlığın Sonu gerçekten
geriye doğru insanlar soru Çünkü az önce
söyledim yediklerimiz içtiklerimiz Bizim
genetik yapımızı bile değiştiriyor O
zaman biz geriye doğru gıdalar yersek
bizim sağlığımıza ne olur Bakalım onu
siz hesap edin Bununla ilgili yapılmış
hiçbir insan çalışması yok yani geride
olduğu gıdaların insan sağlığına ne
yaptığına dair hiçbir çalışma yok ama
başlangıçta yapılmış birkaç para deneyi
var benim el olur dediğinde velileri ol
sadece kobay farelerine GDO'lu yan yana
kobay fareleri 3 jenerasyonda tam kısır
olmuş
3 jenerasyonda tam kısır olmuş İnsanoğlu
kaç yıldır kendi oğlu gıda yiyor 95'ten
koyar 95 öncesinde GDO yok 89'u 2 patent
95 ilk ürün dünyada piyasaya çıktı
95'ten böyle hani Henüz bir jenerasyon
bile geçmedi ki evde olduk hal üçüncü
jenerasyonda Ya insanlar da tam kısa
olursa ne diyeceğiz Acaba bugün
kısırlığın artmasının altında yatan
sebeplerden birisi bu olabilirdi Niye
her mahallede bir tüp bebek merkezi var
Neden çocuklar artık normal yollardan
çocuk sahibi olamıyorlardı bu gençlerin
niye tüp bebek tedavisi veriyoruz Bir
beslenmelerini düzeltme önce daha iyi
olmaz mı İşte söylediğim şey bu
sağlığınızı korumak için beslenme
genelde bu niye yapılır açığı engellemek
için falan değil Geo patent demek için
yapılır dünyada açlık emperyalizmin
üstünden vardır sömürge ülkeleri açlık
çeker Eğer insanları aç kalmasını
istemiyor
o gıdadaki adaletle dağıtımı
sağlamalısınız dünyada şu anda üretilen
tarım ürünlerinin yarısı son tüketiciye
gitmeden çöpe atılıyor Biz Amerika'nın
çöpe attığı gıda yağı çöpe atmasa ve
açılara yedirirsek Dünyada ki tüm açları
soyulmamız mümkün geride onun açlığı
engellemekle alakası yoktur açlık
emperyalizm ile ilgili bir sorundur
açtığı heykele yapılmaz ki O patent için
yapılır GDO da ya da hep birlikte doğum
yaptığı tohumu sahibi olan o firma firma
o tohumu satarak para kazanır yani
Gerede Onun da kibritin de ana sebebi ne
açlık ve insan sağlığdır tamamen ticaret
yapıyor paradaki başka bir şey değil
yemek tohum Bugün bizim başımızda olan
kısır tohumu bugün günümüzde gibi
tohumla tarım yapıyor Türkiye'de ve
tarım yasaları hibrit ruhunu destekliyor
tarım ilacı denilen zehirleri anlatmaya
gerek yok
size çok basit bir şey söyleyeyim niye
bunu söylediğimi anlayacaksınız tarım
ilaçlarıyla kanser arasındaki ilişkiyi
gösteren dünyada bir tek yayın bile yok
buna var mı bu olmayabilir mi çalışması
bile yok düşünün artık arka planda neler
var glikoz zaten en tehlikeli tarım
ilacı ayrı kutu ilacı çok uzatmak
istemem ama şunu bilmenizi istiyorum
bugün ülkemizde kontrolsüz bir şekilde
kullanılıyor ve Vitamin mineral
eksikliklerin altında yatan gluten
intolerans tablosunun altında yatan ana
sebep kaliforaptır son derece
tehlikelidir zamanını verimli kullanmak
ve bitirmek için hızlanıyorum bu
detaylara girmeyeceğim kimyasal katkı
maddeleri yine aynı şekilde ama şunu
vurgulamak istiyorum
sağlıklı yaşaması mümkün ama
görmelisiniz önce gıdamızı Dostlar
bozulan gıda sağlığımızı bozdu
sonra da bize ömür boyu kullanmamız için
birtakım ilaçları iyileştirmeyen
ilaçların sattılar olay budur olayında
bunu görmeniz gerekir önce gıdığınıza
sahip çıkmalısınız ki sağlıklı yaşayın
Peki ne yapmamız gerekir nasıl ilaçsız
ve sağlıklı yaşayacağız Bu mümkün bunun
Yolları var bunu Yeter ki Yapmak isteyin
Biz hastalanıyoruz Evet ama siz
kendinizi koruyabilirsiniz çok basit bir
şekilde özetleyeceğim önce bir kendi
mutfağınıza sahip çıkın işlenmiş
gıdalardan kurtuldum o cipslerden krem
çikolatalardan kurtuldum kendi
yoğurdunuzu mayalamaya başlayın tencere
yemeği yapmaya başlıyorum çocuklarınıza
yemek yapmaya öğretin turşu kurmayı
öğretin bir basit anlamda bunlarla
başlayın bakın daha böyle şekere
gelmedik Öncelikle bunları oturtun
hayatınızda Ondan sonra işte tatlıdan
şekerden karbonhidrattan glutenden uzak
bir hayat çizmeye çalışın her gün
egzersiz yapın Sigaradan alkolden uzak
durun Bunlar o kadar da zor şeyler değil
şunu unutmayın bizim sağlığımızı
koruyacak kimse yok hiçbir kurum bizi
korumayacak bizim sağlığımızı koruyacak
olan ve şifaya ulaşacak olan bizzat
biziz Her birimiz kendimizi
koruyabiliriz ancak başka hiç kimse bizi
koruyamaz Dünyada hiçbir otorite Sen
hastalanma diye şunu yap diyor dünyadaki
tüm otomateler Sen hastalar güzel
kardeşim ben sana ilacını bekliyorum
diyor Eğer siz hastalanmadan bir ilaçsız
yaşamak istiyorsanız kendi hayatınızı
kontrolüne elinize almak zorundasınız
kendi sağlığınızı Siz koruyacaksınız
hepsi bir tercih meselesidir dünyanın en
iyi en pahalı arabasına da binmek
isteyebilirsiniz
bir Model düşük araba alayım kendime iki
dönüm tarla alayım da diyebilirsiniz bu
mümkündür yapılmayacak bir şey değildir
şehirde de yapılır şehrin dışında da
yapılır ama yeter ki siz isteyin bunu
buna ulaşamıyorsanız Pekala 4 aile 5
aile birleşip tıpkı bir kooperatif kurar
gibi arkadaşlarınızla kendi çiftliğinizi
yapabilirsiniz yine bu da bir tercih
meselesidir Pahalı değildir İşletmesi
zordur O yüzden Emek Birliği yapmakta
fayda var ama sağlığımızı korumak
istiyorsanız en önce gıdanınızı
korumalısınız mutfağınızı korumalısınız
bunu lütfen unutmayın
hastalanmadan ve ilaç kullanmadan
yaşamak mümkün merak etmeyin
bitirirken şifa ile ilgili olarak
pilimiz ibn-i Sina'nın sosyal üretilmek
istiyorum
İbni Sina diyor ki şifası olmayan
hastalık yoktur irade eksikliğinden
başka değersiz bitki yoktur bilgi
eksikliğinden başka bu da fitoterapinin
bilimsel önceki tarifidir teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]